[MUSIC PLAYING]
Whether you're young,
whether you're old,
age is literally
just a number.
What's important is making
sure to move and move well.
All I need you to do is follow
me and believe in yourself.
I was a college football player.
I had an injury.
I hurt my ankle really bad.
I had depression.
I needed to fix my body
and my emotional state if I
was going to physically heal.
I realized my work was going to
be working on myself and seeing
how I could then
impact other people.
My personal fitness
and wellness philosophy
is called The Ocho System.
It focuses on putting physical
health first and then seeing
how that applies to other
areas of personal wellness
to produce best results.
It's flexible, and it can
meet you where you are.
So you want to do
the bare minimum
to be effective to really
expedite your goals.
Let's just be better
consistently every day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this MasterClass,
you're going
to be an active participant
in your wellness practices.
So I'm going to teach
you about nutrition
and then, also, how to
actually create your workouts.
Let's go.
So I know what you're thinking.
I try to flex my bicep.
I don't see anything.
Well, that doesn't mean you
don't have muscles, okay?
Everybody has muscle.
I hope you get a little bit
more or uncover the muscle
that you already have as you
get stronger, you feel better.
A little bit of muscle and
a little bit of strength
goes a long way as we age.
When we talk about
eating with intent,
what I want you to realize is
when we eat, it has a purpose.
Research shows if I
chop up broccoli and let
it sit for about 90 minutes,
it unlocks the compound
in the broccoli that could
help control your blood sugar
and has anticancer properties.
All right, I would
say good luck,
but you don't need luck
because you're already here.
You'll just show up
and put in the work.
Let go of your concept
of trying to be perfect.
You may be normal weight.
You may be overweight.
You may be underweight.
It doesn't matter.
You have a body.
You're alive.
Thank yourself.
At the end of the day,
you just need you.
I'm Joe Holder, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]